what would an enemy want to do to the
people of Hawaii
during wartime they would want to cut us
off from international shipping well
this is what the law does to us all the
time
my name is Ken schooland I'm a professor
of economics at Hawaii Pacific
University and I'm on the board of
scholars of the grassroot institute of
Hawaii I think the biggest problem
facing the state of Hawaii today is the
Jones Act and I'm extremely grateful to
attorney John Carroll for bringing a
lawsuit that challenges this on the
grounds of Interstate Commerce the Jones
Act is a law that was passed in the
1920s to protect the American shipping
industry from competition basically the
result of this has been that many parts
of the country now are cut off from
ninety percent of all the world's
shipping because of this law that says
any ships that go from one American port
to another American port have to be on
an American vessel that means that they
have to spend much much more money to
pay for American ships that were built
in American ports owned by American
companies at a much higher cost to bring
things to Hawaii from California for
example the Hawaii is cut off from
ninety percent of all the world's
shipping at much much lower rates in
bringing things here to the islands
consider the the words of the economist
Henry George who said protectionism in
all of its forms does to your own people
in peacetime what the enemy would do to
in wartime and consider what what would
an enemy want to do to the people of
Hawaii during wartime they would want to
cut us off from international shipping
that's what the effect of of a hurricane
would be to to cut us off from
international shipping well this is what
the law does to us all the time not just
turn in a moment of emergency the
president recently waived this
requirement after Hurricane sandy in the
East Coast to allow international
shipping to bring supplies to the
destitute people in New York in that
area well why should we just get this
access to the world shipping at much
much lower rates during an emergency
time it should be happening all the time
because our economy essentially is e and
always
an emergency a ship that's going from
China to Los Angeles have to bypass
Hawaii here we are in the middle of the
the Atlantic where all the shipping is
going back and forth and it has to
bypass OE
we could be certainly as rich and
prosperous as Singapore or Hong Kong if
we were allowed to have the access to
the world if you look in the harbor here
a hundred years ago the harbor and Pearl
Pearl Harbor was filled with ships from
all over the world foreign flags in
abundance and now hardly anything
certainly Alaska and Hawaii are put in
an enormous competitive disadvantage by
this Jones Act which affects them much
more so because we don't have the
alternatives of trucking and railroad
transportation we think that being
totally self-sufficient by cutting off
the rest of the world and we could
produce all of our own things then we
lose out the opportunity for enormous
benefits from the comparative advantage
by the specialization and division of
labor by being able to buy products from
around the world and to sell to the
whole world the things that we are
well-suited to produce I mean consider
bananas and and agricultural products
and sugar and pineapple things that
could be sent to the world much much
more cheaply if we were allowed to
access all these other this other
shipping but Hawaii can't serve the
world and we can't be served by the
world
you